merci en fait je peux passer beaucoup de
messages parce que j'ai eu beaucoup de
messages à passer mais les situations
étaient loués en effet ma famille
étaient inquiets je suis tout le temps
en contact avec tout le monde
heureusement pour l'instant nous avons
l'internet les on marche
quand vous me demandez il ya encore deux
semaines vous savez j'ai regardé j'ai
pensé que j'avais une vie mais
complètement dingue j'étais over booké
de partout j'avais des projets à gérer
je me disais mon dieu mais c'est pas
possible comme enjeu je survis dans
cette situation aujourd'hui je me dis
mon dieu mais quelle vie heureuse j'ai
eu encore il ya deux semaines parce que
en plus de tout ça aujourd'hui c'est
finalement je suis complètement dans
cette bulle guerre avec la gestion de
différentes choses et ça c'est pas que
mon cas c'est le cas de tous les
ukrainiens aujourd'hui qu'ils vivent
sans france partout dans le monde et
surtout en ukraine
les ukrainiens en ukraine je dirais
qu'ils sont très unis et vous le voyez
très bien nous avons réussi à tourner le
cours de l'histoire déjà depuis ces
quelques jours vous attendu à sa fin du
tout mais personne ne s'attend cette
résistance et résistance on le savait on
s'attendait pas mais on sait comment on
agit on dit traditionnellement dans un
village ukrainien on peut avoir
plusieurs groupements qui sont un peu et
nuit les avec les autres mais dès qu'il
ya un ami extérieur qui arrivent ils se
regroupent et le combattre et
historiquement parlant le crâne ça reste
un pays un peu avec une histoire
difficile mais c'est un pipe qui n'est
pas guerrier c'est un pays avec une
belle histoire longue qui a huit cents
ans déjà 800 ans de plus que moscou
quant à kiev déjà elle avait les
magnifiques églises et il y avait
là les écritures des on écrivait des
belles histoires là en russie c'était
encore démarré il y avait déjà pas des
grenouilles qui croissent et dans l'est
dans les marais mais c'est tout d'abord
dire que les ukrainiens aujourd'hui ils
n'ont absolument aucun doute aucune
question ne se pose sur la victoire très
rapide et prochaine de l'ukraine je sais
que je suis on me demandait souvent mal
à intervenir sur différents plateaux
télé depuis le premier jour avec le
général on s'est croisé aussi sur
quelques plateaux je crois on a eu les
débats là dessus et on voit à quel point
cette détermination ukrainienne joue
pour changer l'histoire parce que au
début personne ne croyait en notre
victoire rapide on était tous abasourdis
mais comment est-ce possible qu'est ce
qui arrive réveillez moi finalement on
s'est réveillé et c'était déjà là les
chars étaient en ukraine donc il fallait
se mobiliser les ukrainiens se sont
mobilisés très vite et ils ont réussi ce
qu'ils ont réussi à faire c'est-à-dire
ralentir cette armée soit disant la
deuxième armée plus piste alors on nous
dit que ce soir à l'ats que la
détermination des ukrainiens après 15
jours de grève de bombardement d'un pays
encerclée depuis du sud vers le nord
avec kiev pour objectif dont on ne sait
pas effectivement la finalité la
détermination est toujours assez forte
patriotisme départ qu'il est décuplée
sait pas toujours si fortis est de plus
en plus fort tous les jours de plus en
plus fort et surtout chaque bombe chaque
inquiète qui tombe sur nos terres ça
nous donne encore plus de rage à
combattre est arrivé et à punir l'ennemi
hier le conseiller militaire du
président zelensky qui s'appelle alexia
ristovic tout le monde d'aujourd'hui on
appelle on dit c'est notre calme en a
tous parce que lui c'est il est
extraordinaire c'est vraiment quelqu'un
de très professionnel il a dit avant
mario paul avoir le bombardement de
la maternité
c'était rien pour vous il s'est adressé
aux russes il dit aujourd'hui vous allez
avoir une autre guerre et aujourd'hui
tout ce qu'on voit sur les champs de
bataille on voit que l'armée russe ne
progresse pas finalement et quand je
vous entends tous parlé vous dites oui
la troisième guerre l'armée puissante et
cetera mais en réalité on peut parler
d'un autre scénario c'est pas tout à
fait ça parce que quand on sait à quel
niveau il y à la corruption en russie en
quel niveau il ya les détournements des
budget de l'armée au secours du scénario
c'est quoi la vôtre c'est moi j'arrive
j'arrive quand vous avez que vous voyez
aujourd'hui les militaires qui sont au
fond ils ont les rations qui ce qui date
de 2015 qui sont périmés ils n'ont rien
à manger ils sont allé voler des dde
dans les poulaillers des paysans donc
comment nous par exemple que nos coûts
nous qui connaissons très bien on peut
imaginer la vraie menace qui viennent de
7,2 de ce pays on sait très bien que ça
marchera pas et même je vous dirais que
vous bien sûr un apport de menace
nucléaire on a tous peur qu'il appuie
sur le bouton moi je vous dis s'il
appuie sur le bouton rien et sortira
tout est rouillée où tous les fils son
congé par les rats
non mais ya rien de moins sûr il est
nommé à la il faut qu'on avance parce
que c'est pourtant nous avons jeux
appelés rue profiter un maximum
d'émotions que le bateau sont rouillés
ya rien n'est moins sûr donc on va se
calmer là dessus et je préfère ne sais
pas si vous mais moi ça sera mieux que
ça ne marchait pas la relation les
ukrainiens au peuple russe
moi je vous le dis j'ai envie d'avoir
votre avis ces deux peuples son frère ou
sont pas frères en plus frère mais il ya
plus deux frères russes
des peuples je parle pas du choix de vos
meilleurs ou simple mais bien évidemment
proximité avec ristourne
non il faut dire déjà il faut pas
mélanger
les ukrainiens ne sont absolument pas
parer aux russes les rues sont
collectiviste les kolkhozes tout ça
elles ont inventé chez eux les russes et
le peuple reçoit rodez plage ou sur
l'écologie là où l'eau collectée vie ça
canarde fils d'ouvrier
ces panneaux et lauriane et non
stakhanov sa sé ta nou craignant qui
fait il lui même qui fait les syndicats
tandis que oui tandis que les kolkhozes
c'est collectivisme tout cas voilà il
faut réunir il faut être ensemble il
faut souffrir ensemble les ukrainiens
c'est pas du tout ça les ukrainiens
elles sont fort indépendant elle se bat
pour eux pour leur pays pour leur petit
lopin de faire et quand vous vous et à
un oignon soviétique j'étais petite on
prenait le train il n'y avait pas de
frontières entre les républiques ont
traversé avec dans le train on était à
l'intérieur on savait très bien antoine
l'ukraine s'arrêter quand on rentre en
russie parce que en ukraine les maisons
d'ukraine par les attendait il y avait
les maisons qui étaient très jolie et
pitt ont traversé la frontière les
maisons étaient toutes détruites il y
avait l'alcoolisme pas possible et
aujourd'hui ça continue donc pour nous
la différence est nette malheureusement
la population souffre parce que elle est
complètement sous la coupe de la
propagande wissant le plan mais excusez
moi dans les années
70-80 la propagande ça pouvait marcher
parce qu'il n'y avait pas ça aujourd'hui
ils ont l'accès à tous ils n'ont pas
fait le bon choix ils n'ont pas lu les
bonnes les bonnes sources il était
coutume à couper juste poutine n'a rien
couper encore aux jo c'est à dire
aujourd'hui c'est couper mais c'était
pas couper encore il ya deux semaines
voilà donc aujourd'hui les russes
malheureusement il y a les russes j'ai
des amis russes j'ai des amis russes qui
sont des gens extérieurs est rimbaud
gère beaucoup oui et nous distinguons
nos amis russes et après il ya toute la
population qui à 75% aujourd'hui
soutient leur leader ils sont là à dire
vous et très bien on continue et tant
qu'ils étaient tous ensemble le disait
la crimée est à nous ils étaient tous
contents mais comment c'est possible
comment on peut dire aujourd'hui que ce
peuple c'est un peuple frère c'est pas
le top ce jour là